LIKE MY CLOSING STATEMENTS AT
THE END OF THE SHOW.
FIRST TO ANOTHER CRITICAL TOPIC
TONIGHT.
THE LEFT’S PUSH TO FURTHER THEIR
BRAD CAL AGENDA BY BY FACING THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> THE REPUBLICANS STOLE TWO
SEATS ON THE SUPREME COURT, NOW
IT’S UP TO US TO REPAIR THAT
DAMAGE.
WE MUST EXPAND THE COURT AND
ABOLISH THE FILIBUSTER TO DO IT.
>> SOME PEOPLE WILL SAY WE ARE
PACKING THE COURT.
WE ARE UNPACKING IT.
JUDGE JEANINE: SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM JOINS ME TO REACT TO
THAT.
FIRST QUESTION TO YOU.
WHEN THEY SAY THE SUPREME COURT
IS BROKEN AND THEY NEED TO FIX
IT.
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
>> IT’S CONSERVATIVE AND THEY
WANTED IT TO BE LIBERAL.
THERE IS NOTHING BROKEN ABOUT
THE SUPREME COURT.
THERE ARE 9 JUSTICES.
IT’S BEEN THAT WAY SINCE 1869.
THEY WANT TO TURN IT UPSIDE DOWN
TO PACK IT WITH LIBERALS.
EVERY TIME ONE PARTY TAKES OVER
FROM THE OTHER WE’LL CHANGE THE
NUMBER OF JUSTICES.
YOU HAVE YOU BEEN A LAWYER ALL
YOUR LIFE.
IT WILL DESTROY THE RULE OF LAW
AS WE KNOW IT.
THE IDEA OF PACKING THE COURT SO
LIBERALS CAN MAKE IT LIBERAL
RATHER THAN CHANGING THE MICKUP
THROUGH THE ELECTION PROCESS THE
WAY WE HAVE DON’T FOR A LONG
TIME.
THIS IS A DRAMATIC BOLD MOVE AND
I WILL DO EVERYTHING WITHIN MY
POWER TO STOP IT IN THE SENATE.
IF IT WROTE BECOME A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL.
JUDGE JEANINE: THERE IS NO
QUESTION IT WOULD BE JUST
ANOTHER BRANCH OF POLITICAL
GOVERNMENT.
EVEN RUTH BADER GINSBURG SAID IT
WAS A BAD IDEA TO PACK THE
COURT.
THEY CAN RULE ON ANYTHING.
THEY CAN RULE ON THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
ON ABORTION.
ON UNIONS.
ON ANY ONE OF A NUMBER OF
ISSUES.
IT DOESN’T MATTER.
>> THE COURT MATTERS.
>> TO ALL OF US.
I WANT TO MOVE ON BECAUSE THERE
ALWAYS LOT OF NEWS.
TODAY PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID FOR
THE FIRST TIME THAT THE -- THAT
THERE WAS A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
I THINK WE HAVE SOME SOUND ON
THAT.
>> THE PROBLEM WAS THE
REFUGEES --
JUDGE JEANINE: IT’S NOT CLEAR
WHAT HE’S TALKING ABOUT.
BUT HE INITIALLY SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO CAPTAIN REFUGEES AT
15,000 AND AOC HAS A CONNIPTION
AND HE ADMITS THERE IS A CRISIS
AT THE BORDER.
>> IT’S CHAOS.
WE HAD 172,000 PEOPLE COME INTO
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY IN MARCH
ALONE.
WE ARE ON TRACK TO DO 2 MILLION.
THE BORDER PATROL TOLD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DURING THE
TRANSITION.
IF YOU REVERSE POLICY ON THE
BORDER.
YOU HAVE THE RUSSIAN THREATENING
THE UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT.
THE CHINESE THREATENING TAIWAN.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE THE
TALIBAN TAKES CARE OF AL QAEDA
AND ISIS.
JOE BIDEN CREATED A LOT OF
INSTABILITY IN WHAT SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME.
IF HE DOESN’T GET TOUGHER WITH
THE IRANIANS THEY WILL HAVE A
BOMB BEFORE YOU KNOW IT.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT THE WORLD
UNDER THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE CLUELESS IN MY VIEW IN
TERMS OF THE THREATS WE FACE AT
THE BORDER AND ABROAD.
JUDGE JEANINE: LET’S TALK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
I KNOW YOU FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT
IT.
THERE ARE 2,500 MILITARY FORCES
THERE.
WHY ARE YOU SO AGAINST REMOVING
THEM?
>> THEY ARE AN INSURANCE POLICY
AGAINST ANOTHER 9/11.
THE LAST TYPE WE IGNORED
AFGHANISTAN WE HAD 3,000
AMERICANS KILLED.
AFGHANISTAN WAS A SAFE HAVEN FOR
AL QAEDA.
HAVE WE LEARNED NOTHING FROM
IRAQ?
WHEN WE WITHDRAW FROM THESE
PLACES AND DON’T HAVE AN
INSURANCE POLICY RESIDUAL FORCE
TO WATCH THE BAD GUYS, THEY COME
BACK HERE.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE YOUR FOOT ON
THEIR THROAT OVER THERE, THEY
FIGHT OVER HERE.
WE HAD 3 THUNDERSHOWERSO -- WE H
FOLKS ON THE GROUND.
I THINK BIND LEFT US NAKED.
I’M WORRIED WE’LL PAY A HEAVY
PLACE FOR LEAVING AFGHANISTAN.
THEY WILL COME ROARING BACK AND
WE’LL HAVE TO GO BACK IN.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME, BELIEVE
THE MILITARY.
HE WAS ADVISED NOT TO DO THIS
IRAQ, HE DID IT.
HE WAS ADVISED NOT TO DO IT IN
AFGHANISTAN AND HE DID IT
ANYWAY.
HE WAS TOLD BY THE BORDER PATROL
DON’T CHANGE TRUMP POLICIES, YOU
WILL LOSS CONTROL OF THE BORDER.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT THE STATE OF
THE WORLD UNDER JOE BIDEN.